5 25 on your wednesday morning well we
got a viewer email that's earning us all
a free trip to traffic 101.
viewer deborah writes i moved here two
years ago still can't believe the number
of drivers who have no clue what to do
at four-way stops seriously there should
be a public service announcement between
them and the speeders i'm lucky to get
home with no car damage
well deborah here are a couple of quotes
from our friends at the nevada
department of motor vehicles at a
four-way stop the driver reaching the
intersection first gets to go first
after stopping completely
also at a four-way stop wait for other
vehicles already in the intersection
allow vehicles that reach the
intersection before you to go first wait
your turn
all right well thank you so much for
debra for riding in and just in case you
are new to driving world we'll go ahead
and say if two or more drivers arrive at
a four-way at the same time the driver
furthest to the right gets to go first
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone something's trapping you
crazy email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com